Vorsicht bei der Einfahrt.
Sonntagmorgen Bahnhof Berlin-Ostkreuz. Eigentlich viel zu früh. Am Bahnsteig warten auffällig viele ausflugshungrige Städter. Einige davon wollen auch einmal ein heutiges Ziel. Fürstenberg an der Havel in Brandenburg. Chaosradio Spezial. Der Verstehbahnhof. Ein Hack- und Makespace auf dem Land. Von Daniel Molkenthin. Nach etwa 80 Minuten Fahrt erreiche ich mein Ziel. Mein Weg führt mich durch eine Unterführung vorbei an einem kleinen Café zum Bahnungsvorplatz. Von hier aus starten die meisten meiner Mitreisenden ihren Ausflug in die Natur. Von seinem Grundstück auf der anderen Seite des Platzes wiegt mir mein heutiger Gesprächspartner zu. Er begleitet mich zurück zum Bahnhofsgebäude am Gleis 1. Wir treten ein. In einer geräumigen Werkstatt, voll mit 3D-Druckern, Lasercuttern und allem, was das Meckerherz höher schlagen lässt, setzen wir uns.
Ich war in der Vergangenheit in meinem Leben in unterschiedlichen Kontexten, in verschiedenen Airfars unterwegs und bin 2011 mit meiner Familie hier rausgezogen, nach Fürstenberg, auf der Suche nach etwas mehr Ruhe und Distanz von der Stadt und ein paar anderen Dingen. Naja, und so sind wir hier 2011 gelandet.
Das mit den anderen Dingen wollte ich aber dann doch nochmal genauer wissen.
Im Moment können das wahrscheinlich noch mehr Leute nachvollziehen aufgrund der Corona-Situation und der Enge, die eine Stadt dann irgendwie mit sich bringt. Wir wollten einfach raus und ein bisschen mehr Platz haben, so Platz für Ideen, auch bezahlbaren Raum. Wir haben vorher in Mitte gelebt, das war super praktisch, weil ich es nicht weit hatte in die Marienstraße und überhaupt quasi mittendrin war im Geschehen der Stadt. Gleichzeitig sind die Mieten durch die Decke gegangen, das wurde alles irgendwie immer teurer. Man hatte keine Möglichkeit, einen Rückzugsort so wirklich zu haben und geschweige denn irgendwie Platz zu haben für Ideen, die man irgendwie hätte. Und das kennen, glaube ich, in der aktuellen Situation immer mehr Leute, die sich jetzt mit genau der gleichen Frage beschäftigen, nämlich wo kann man hingehen, wenn man aus dieser Enge und diesem Kostenwahnsinn irgendwie raus möchte, aber gleichzeitig ja nicht irgendwo in der Pampa sitzen will. Und wir haben 2011 damals so ein bisschen um Berlin gesucht. Also wir wollten nicht zu weit weg, aber auch nicht zu nah dran sein. Wir haben uns überlegt, dass es irgendwie eine vernünftige Verkehrsanbindung braucht. Man will ja mal in die Stadt, aber man will auch irgendwie besuchbar sein für Leute, dass man nicht alle Kontakte verliert. Gleichzeitig sollte das irgendwie eine einigermaßen ordentliche Internetinfrastruktur haben. Und wir wollten gerne irgendwo in die Natur. Und dann haben wir so ein bisschen geguckt. Der Speckgürtel fällt raus. Das ist irgendwie halt gar nicht wirklich draußen. Das ist so nichts Halbes und nichts Ganzes. Im Osten Berlins gibt es oder östlich von Berlin ist die Verkehrsanbindung relativ schlecht. Westen Richtung Potsdam ist einfach unbezahlbar und auch nicht besonders attraktiv. Und im Süden hat uns das irgendwie damit nichts gefunden. Und dann kamen wir aufgrund von einer Bekannten, die wir hier haben in Fürstenberg ein paar Mal im Sommer nach draußen und haben einfach festgestellt, dass uns das hier total gut gefällt. Da haben wir ein kleines Häuschen gefunden hier. War so eine verrückte Idee. Wir haben uns das dann angeguckt und irgendwie hat das dann alles funktioniert und wir sind in relativ kurzer Zeit dann hier mit Sack und Pack rausgezogen.
Die Idee für einen großflächigen Space bestand nicht von Anfang an, aber Räumlichkeiten waren von Anfang an wichtig.
Wir haben also auf der einen Seite festgestellt, das ist total gut hier draußen. Uns fehlt hier eigentlich überhaupt nichts. Das war alles das, was wir so erwartet haben. Das einzige, was uns irgendwie relativ schnell bewusst wurde, war, dass wir trotzdem hier draußen wenig Leute haben, die sich für ähnliche Themen interessieren wie wir. Und dann kam, glaube ich, so ein bisschen diese Erkenntnis, dass soziale Räume, wo man sich mit Leuten treffen kann, die sich für ähnliche Themen interessieren. Und Leute, die wussten, die Möglichkeit gibt, sich auszutauschen, dass man darauf halt trotzdem nicht irgendwie verzichten kann. So hat sich die Frage, glaube ich, irgendwann 2011 oder 12 dann schon so gestellt, wie man perspektivisch, ob das nicht Sinn machen würde, zu versuchen, einen solchen Ort hier draußen irgendwie zu entwickeln. Wir waren eine ganze Weile eigentlich noch mit uns selbst und dem Ausbau von unserem Haus und allen möglichen anderen Sachen beschäftigt. Aber wir haben uns eben Gedanken gemacht darüber, und haben diesen ganzen Ideen, die wir hatten, irgendwie diesen Namen Havel Lab gegeben. Das war damals eigentlich noch unser Privathaus und wir dachten, das ist quasi so eine Art Ideenstätte, wo wir uns Gedanken drüber machen, was wir hier alles vorhaben in der Stadt und haben dem Ganzen halt einfach einen Namen gegeben damals.
Der Verstehbahnhof ist heute vor allem ein Ort für Kinder und Jugendliche, die mehr über den Umgang mit Technik lernen wollen. Auf dem Weg dahin spielte ausgerechnet ein Sportgerät eine maßgebliche Rolle.
Ich habe aufgrund meiner persönlichen Vergangenheit mir irgendwann auf Ebay so ein gebrauchtes Turnier-Trampolin angelacht für unseren Garten. Immer so gedacht, wenn ich mal irgendwann Platz habe, hätte ich sowas gerne. Das ist so eine Art Kindheitstrauma, das ich mit mir rum trage und ich glaube, so 2014 ging das irgendwie los, dass Kinder bei uns an der Tür geklingelt haben, die dann wissen wollten, ob sie irgendwie zu uns in den Garten auf das Trampolin drauf dürfen. Und dann hat sich mit diesen Kids irgendwie so ein Dialog ergeben. Die haben irgendwann gefragt, warum ich eigentlich so viel zu Hause bin. Die dachten, ich bin vielleicht arbeitslos oder habe irgendwie nichts zu tun oder was auch immer. Und dann habe ich denen halt erklärt, dass ich die meiste Zeit so von zu Hause aus arbeiten kann, weil ich mit dem Computer arbeite und dann wollten die wissen, was ich mache. Und dann habe ich mal irgendwann die ersten Kids zu mir nach drinnen eingeladen in meine kleine Werkstatt. Und wir haben so ein bisschen ein paar Lötprojekte gemacht, irgendwie Pentabugs gelötet oder irgendwelche anderen kleinen Projekte. Dann haben wir mal so das erste kleine Programmierprojekt gemacht. Und so hat sich das über eine Zeit von vielen Monaten oder eigentlich Jahren ausgewachsen und ist eigentlich aber organisch gewachsen, dass wir immer mehr Kontakte hatten, was das betrifft. Also es kamen immer mehr Kids, die gehört haben, dass bei uns irgendwie man irgendwas Cooles mit Technik machen kann und auf dem Trampolin irgendwie Zeit verbringen kann. Und dann hat die Schule von unserem Sohn mal gefragt, ob wir nicht irgendwie Lust hätten, eine Projektwoche zu machen. Dann hatten wir mal so eine ganze Schulklasse, die zu einer Projektwoche bei uns oben im ausgebauten Dach irgendwie gehaust haben, haben wir Vorträge gemacht, ein bisschen programmiert und gelötet und keine Ahnung. Dann kam die Grundschule und wollte wissen, ob wir so was hier vor Ort nicht in einer regelmäßigen AG machen wollen, montagsnachmittags im PC-Raum von der Schule. Und so wurde das irgendwie alles immer umfangreicher einfach. Und gleichzeitig war klar, also der PC-Raum in der Schule, das ist so die, also die schlechtestmögliche Atmosphäre, in der man irgendwas machen kann. Das ist aufgebaut wie so ein Panoptikum, da sitzt der Lehrer in der Mitte und alle Schüler sitzen mit dem Rücken zum Lehrer im Kreis. Ich habe also so die maximale Möglichkeit zu sehen, dass da keiner irgendwas macht, was er nicht machen soll, aber gleichzeitig ist das so das Gegenteil von Teamwork. Also die Kids können nicht miteinander arbeiten, es gibt überhaupt keine Möglichkeit zu interagieren und gemeinsam an irgendwas zu arbeiten und sich auszutauschen. Das hat mir also hat mir überhaupt nicht gefallen. Und dann haben wir auch festgestellt, dass so cool das ist mit einem ausgebauten Dach und viel Platz im Haus, kann ich jetzt nicht beliebig viele Schulklassen irgendwie in mein Privathaus reinlassen und dann ist total unklar wo jetzt die Trennung ist zwischen den Räumen, wo die jetzt nicht alle reinlaufen sollen einfach so und meiner Werkstatt und dem Raum unterm Dach oben und so haben wir überlegt, dass es eigentlich sinnvoll wäre, dass hier ein bisschen anders aufzuziehen und dann hat sich zwischenzeitlich, das ist jetzt was, was parallel passiert ist, ergeben, dass der Bahnhof verkauft wurde. Das war, glaube ich, 2015 wurde der Bahnhof verkauft von der Deutschen Bahn an eine Privatperson. Das ist unser heutiger Vermieter, der ist so ein bisschen Bahnaffin, hat irgendwie schon immer davon geträumt, einen eigenen Bahnhof zu haben. Der hat auch beim beim Innovationszentrum der Bahn in Berlin gearbeitet, eine ganze Zeit lang und beschäftigt sich so mit Mobilitätsforschung und Mobilität der Zukunft, Städteplanung und so Sachen. Und der hat das also gekauft und hatte dann hier ausgeschrieben im Bahnhof, dass man die leerstehenden Teile des Bahnhofs, ich glaube für ein halbes Jahr oder ein Jahr mietfrei haben kann, wenn man damit irgendwas Cooles machen will. Und das hat Michel angelockt. Michel hat einen Getränke laden in Berlin und hat irgendwie auch ein bisschen davon geträumt, aufs Land zu kommen und hier draußen irgendwie ein Projekt zu machen. Und der hat das irgendwo in der Zeitung gelesen, kam dann hier raus und ist gegenüber von unserem Haus in diesem Bahnhof eingezogen. Und das waren also so ein paar Räume, in denen dann eine WG entstanden ist, ein bisschen Zimmervermietung über Zeit und vor allem aber auch die alte Wartehalle, die Teil dieses gemieteten Objekts von ihm war. Und in dieser alten Wartehalle, naja, die schrie halt so ein bisschen nach Veranstaltung. Und Michel hat dann am Anfang mit ein paar anderen Akteuren hier gemeinsam versucht, da eine Kunstausstellung mal anzubieten. Und es gab mal ein Konzert und so unterschiedliche Formate, die ausprobiert wurden. Und das hat alles, glaube ich, nicht so richtig funktioniert. Also, das war in keinem guten Zustand. Da waren auch nicht genug Leute da, die mithelfen wollten, das mal zu ein bisschen zu renovieren und auf Vordermann zu bringen. Und gleichzeitig ist das zwar sehr zentral, aber doch nicht so, dass jemand jetzt zufällig durch die Halle läuft, um sich eine Ausstellung anzugucken oder so. Und dann haben wir 2017 gemeinsam hier alle eigentlich gesagt, warum machen wir nicht in der Halle die Bildungsprojekte? Warum ziehe ich nicht um mit der AG aus der Schule in die Halle? Und wir eröffnen ein bisschen einen Raum, den Kids nutzen können, um an coolen Projekten zu arbeiten. Und dann haben wir uns, wir fanden das eigentlich alle direkt ziemlich gut, haben uns dann 2017 zusammengesetzt, haben aus dieser HavelLab-Idee einen Verein gemacht. Also das ist der HavelLab e.V. der jetzt ein eingetragener und gemeinnütziger Verein ist. Und mit diesem Verein haben wir angefangen, die Halle zu bespielen. Und so ist quasi diese erste Iteration des Verstehbarenhofs entstanden, dass wir in der alten Wartehalle ein bisschen Infrastruktur aufgebaut haben, eine kleine Bühne, einen ordentlichen Beamer, eine Leinwand, so ein bisschen Veranstaltungstechnik und gleichzeitig irgendwie drei Stapel mit Stapelstühlen für eine Schulklasse, Klapptische, die wir aufbauen können für bis zu 30 Kinder, damit man mit so einer ganzen Klasse was machen kann und eine Kiste Laptops und einen Haufen Lötstationen. Und dann war eigentlich so ein improvisiertes Setup da und wir haben gesagt, Montagnachmittag findet das jetzt nicht mehr in der Schule statt, sondern wer Bock hat, der kommt einfach in den Bahnhof. Und so haben wir 2017, so im späten Herbst, die ersten Kids hier im Bahnhof gehabt, mit denen wir angefangen haben, einfach hier in einem viel offeneren Ort und in einem ganz anderen Format, als das in der Schule vorher der Fall war, an Projekten zu arbeiten.
Ich befürchte, dass hauptsächlich Jungs zu diesen Veranstaltungen kommen. Daniel schüttelt mit dem Kopf.
Wir haben total großes Glück, dass wir eine sehr gemischte Teilnehmergruppe haben. Gerade die jungen Leute, die aus dem Ort zu uns kommen, da haben wir eigentlich alles dabei. Von den Kindern, die noch in der Gemeinschaftsunterkunft leben, also irgendwelche geflüchteten Kinder, die in dem lokalen Flüchtlingsheim leben, bis zum Sohn unseres Bürgermeisters, deckt das junge Leute aus ganz unterschiedlichen Kontexten ab. Auch die treffen sich hier und begegnen sich, obwohl sie sich vielleicht sonst in ihrem Freizeitleben überhaupt nicht wirklich begegnen würden. Wir haben extrem viele Mädchen, die auch mitmachen. Das finde ich persönlich total gut. Das hat sich irgendwie so ein bisschen ergeben, dass wir ein paar der quasi zu starken und coolen Mädchen hier akquiriert haben, die mitgemacht haben und die haben dann ihre Freundin mit angeschleppt. So hat sich das eigentlich auch ausgewachsen, dass auch die Mädels mittlerweile verstanden haben, dass es nicht hier darum geht, jetzt möglichst viel am Computer zu nerden. Das ist das, was vielleicht für die weniger interessant ist. Also es ist vielleicht auch ein zu einfaches Stereotyp. Aber so ein bisschen vereinfacht gesagt, glaube ich, ist die Jungsfraktion, die wollen halt vielleicht tendenziell dann doch eher mal zocken oder interessieren sich für Minecraft oder irgendwas in der Art und man holt die halt eher mit Programmierangelegenheiten ab. Während die Mädels, die hier auftauchen, spätestens wenn die den Schneideplotter sehen und den Lasercutter und was man damit halt alles machen kann, dann ist es diese kreative Schiene, die die da anders zieht. Und dann treffen die sich eh früher oder später irgendwo gemeinsam und entdecken die jeweils andere Welt oder andere Facetten. Aber das hat einfach total gut funktioniert.
Auch wenn ich zum Verstehbahnhof gefunden hätte, findet möglicherweise über die Schule dorthin.
Es gibt so Nachmittags-AGs, also typischerweise irgendwelche Sport-Sachen. Es gibt eine Ballsport-AG oder es gibt die Schulgarten-AG. Und genau so hat das auch immer noch diesen schlimmen Titel, die Schule sich damals den Titel für unsere AG ausgedacht. Und das heißt jetzt irgendwie kreativ mit Technik. Ich meine, das ist jetzt vielleicht nicht ganz der spannendste Titel. Auf der anderen Seite ist mir nie was Besseres eingefallen. Das ist auch total egal eigentlich. Das ist also ein Nachmittagsangebot, montags gewesen, nach der Schule. Und es ist bis heute auch nicht irgendwie Teil des Lehrplans oder so. Wir haben mit der lokalen Grundschule hier und auch mit ein paar anderen Schulen, mit zwei Gymnasien hier bei uns in der Gegend eine relativ intensive Kooperation. Also das ist auch alles mittlerweile formalisiert und es gibt richtige Kooperationsverträge. Und dann gibt es Projektwochen oder Ausflüge von Klassen, die dann mal für einen Tag oder so hierher kommen. Aber es ist nicht so, dass wir Regelunterricht machen, in dem Sinne. Man ergänzt sich vielleicht mal, also das hatten wir auch schon, dass es für Regelunterricht irgendwie, dass wir da was beitragen. Aber in den regulären Schulen ist das nicht als Regelunterricht angekommen.
Doch möglicherweise tut sich eine Gelegenheit mit freien Schultagern auf.
Es gibt seit letztem Jahr auch eine freie Naturschule hier und mit denen reden wir jetzt gerade drüber, ob nicht das, was wir hier machen, Teil des Regelunterrichts sein kann. Aber die sind halt in ihrem ganzen Format und der Art und Weise, wie der Lehrplan gestaltet wird und überhaupt wie selbstbestimmt auch gelernt wird, sind die wesentlich flexibler. Und ein bisschen ist das, was wir machen, natürlich hier relativ weit weg von so einem Standard-Lehrplan einer Grundschule in Brandenburg.
Aber auch für Klassen von außerhalb hat der Verstehbahnhof Angebote.
Wir haben Schulklassen, die hier rauskommen für Projekttage. Auch das geht aus Berlin zum Beispiel total gut. Kann man super mit einem Aufenthalt verbinden, macht hier morgens irgendwie Workshop im Bahnhof und geht danach noch mit allen zur Badewiese. Oder wir haben auch Schulklassen, die einfach für eine Projektwoche herkommen. Also dann auch überregional und eigentlich so aus dem ganzen Bundesgebiet. Die kommen dann zum Teil einfach für eine Woche, mieten sich hier mit ihren Zelten auf dem Zeltplatz ein, der ist 300 oder 400 Meter von hier direkt am See gelegen. Dann zelten die da, gehen irgendwie abends oder nachmittags schwimmen, grillen abends so ein bisschen und sind ansonsten tagsüber halt hier in der Werkstatt und machen irgendwie eine coole Projektwoche. Und auch so was geht dann genauso wie, dass wir keine Ahnung, irgendwie einen Dreitalien-Druck-Workshop machen oder irgendwas anderes, was also begrenzt ist auf dieses Format.
Doch klar ist, der Verstehbahnhof ist nicht primär ein Angebot für Schulen.
Wir verstehen uns in der Tat hier, das ist ein Hacker und oder Makerspace, der sich aber primär eigentlich an junge Leute wendet. Also das war so die Idee. Das ist auch Teil der Gemengelage, als wir hier rausgezogen sind. Ich habe mich immer gefragt, also zum einen natürlich, ich will hier nicht wieder wegziehen, sondern das war so der Schritt nach draußen. Und wenn man diesen Schritt wagt, dann fragt man sich früher oder später, was braucht hier dieser Ort, damit ich nicht in 20 Jahren wieder wegziehen muss, weil hier kein Arzt mehr ist oder so. Und dann lag das eigentlich relativ nahe, dass der Umstand, dass junge Leute nicht wegziehen, weil es hier keine Arbeit und keine Perspektive gibt, das lag halt nahe. Und dann habe ich mich gefragt, was könnte man dafür tun, dass junge Leute ähnlich flexibel und unabhängig sind wie ich. Und so kam diese Idee, dass man, wenn man diesen Ort hier errichtet, den Kindern quasi Zugang zu den gleichen Privilegien gibt, die viele von uns in unserer Filterblase, im Umfeld des Clubs oder wie auch immer haben, nämlich dass sie früh die Möglichkeit hatten, sich mit anderen Leuten auszutauschen, von anderen zu lernen, in dieser ganzen lebenslangen Lernkultur rund um Technik groß zu werden, wo wir Dinge miteinander teilen und vor allem Wissen teilen und uns so gegenseitig Perspektiven verschaffen. Und dann war halt die Idee, wenn man diesen Ort jetzt baut, dann baut man das halt so, dass es kind- und jugendgerecht ist, in der Hoffnung, dass man hier vielleicht die Kids anzieht. Und das erste Problem, die erste Herausforderung, die man ganz natürlich hatte, ist, dass es hier viel weniger junge Leute gibt. Die diese Disposition oder diese Interessenslage mitbringen. Also es gibt viel weniger Kinder insgesamt als jetzt in einer Stadt wie Berlin. Und dementsprechend ist statistisch der Anteil derer, die jetzt von alleine wissen, warum dieser Ort für sie total spannend sein kann. Der ist natürlich wesentlich geringer. Also wir haben hier keine besonders riesige Klientel, die wir bedienen gleichzeitig. Und das ist eigentlich das Schöne. Heißt das aber auch, dass für dieses Kernteam an jungen Leuten, die wir jetzt hier haben, also wir haben so eine Größenordnung vielleicht von 10 bis 15 jungen Leuten, die hier sehr, sehr regelmäßig herkommen, für die sind wir halt genau der richtige Ort und auch der einzige Ort, den es gibt. Und die kommen zum Teil von relativ weit weg. Also die müssen dann auch vielleicht mal teilweise auch hergefahren werden von ihren Eltern, weil die irgendwo so weit in der Pampa leben, dass das mit öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln nicht funktioniert. Aber da sind wir halt so ein zentraler Ort, wo sich in einem Einzugsgebiet von vielleicht im Radius von 30 bis 50 Kilometern irgendwie junge Leute auf den Weg machen, um hierher zu kommen. Und dann stellen die ganz anders, auf einer ganz anderen Ebene als in der Stadt, glaube ich, fest, dass sie mit ihren Interessen überhaupt nicht alleine sind, dass es da noch ein paar andere Kids gibt, die halt irgendwie weit weg wohnen, von denen man gar nichts gehört hat, die vielleicht nicht mal auf die, oder in der Regel nicht mal auf die gleiche Schule gehen, sondern das ist halt alles so ein bisschen dezentraler dann. Aber für die ist das halt ein ganz, ganz wichtiger Ort, glaube ich. Und dementsprechend hat sich das hier auch in so eine Sache ausgewachsen, die, glaube ich, total gut angenommen wird und wo die Kids sich sehr stark auch investiert sehen. So, das ist auch was, worauf wir, glaube ich, von Anfang an versucht haben zu achten. Und was uns hoffentlich gelungen ist, dass wir nicht nur einen Ort für Kids bauen hier, sondern dass wir den gemeinsam mit den Kids irgendwie gestalten. Und das junge Leute ist uns ganz wichtig. Wir haben hier eine elektronische Schließanlage und wir haben von Anfang an eigentlich auch jungen Leuten Schlüssel gegeben. Also diese Kerngruppe, die wir hier haben, die haben eigentlich fast alle Schlüssel und können auch unabhängig hier kommen und gehen, wie sie wollen. So die sind aufgefordert dazu, hier Dinge zu verändern, mitzumachen. Und das hat dann irgendwann begonnen mit der Renovierung, die wir hier alle gemeinsam gemacht haben. Und keine Ahnung, sind heute Fragen, wie berichtet man diesen Raum hier weiter ein? Was fehlt uns hier irgendwie? Welche Maschinen hätten wir gerne? Keine Ahnung, also alle so diese Dinge, die da dann mitschwingen.
Im Hintergrund der Werkstatt fällt mir ein riesiges Jugendhack-Banner auf. Ich frage Daniel, was es damit auf sich hat.
Also wir hatten großes Glück, dass manchmal könnte man meinen, das fügt sich hier irgendwie alles so ineinander. Ja, dass also auch vor zwei Jahren die Open Knowledge Foundation und Mediale Pfade, die gemeinsam Jugendhack veranstalten, sich überlegt hatten, neben den Hackathons, die Jugendhack darstellt, irgendwie auch Labs auszukünden. Also Standorte, an denen das Jugendhack-Angebot irgendwie regelmäßiger stattfindet. Und dann gab es dafür so eine Art Bewerbungsprozess. Und wir haben uns hier mit dem Bahnhof natürlich auch darauf beworben und sind gemeinsam mit dem Verschwörhaus in Ulm eines von zwei Jugendhack-Labs, die im Moment aktiv sind. Und dann gibt es ein paar in Cottbus und anderen Standorten, die jetzt als nächstes auch entstehen. Und das ist supergut, weil das sehr komplementär ist und total gut zusammenpasst mit dem, was wir sonst so treiben. Also wir haben, vielleicht kann ich das ja auch kurz erklären, wir haben hier an verschiedenen Nachmittagen eigentlich offen. Also Montag, Dienstag und Mittwoch sind so die drei Nachmittage, an denen wir, wenn jemand da ist, gelegentlich klappt es auch nicht. Aber in der Regel ist es so, dass dann hier aufgeschlossen wird nachmittags. Dann machen wir um 1 Uhr die Tür auf und die Kids können nach der Schule einfach hierher kommen und an Projekten arbeiten. Dann gibt es so ein bisschen unterschiedliche Schwerpunkte, was die Altersstruktur vielleicht angeht an unterschiedlichen Tagen. Aber das ist so das eine, das richtet sich halt primär an die jungen Leute, die quasi nach der Schule in einem sehr direkten Einzugsgebiet hier Dinge tun. Und dann gibt es mit dem Jugend-Hack-Lab jetzt ein Samstagsprogramm, das ist im Moment zweimal im Monat samstags und das wendet sich ja dann eher auch an vielleicht ein bisschen älterer, also zwischen 12 und 18 dann, auch eher an junge Leute, die schon ein bisschen affiner sind vielleicht, auch ein bisschen fortgeschrittener. Ist generell natürlich offen, aber es zieht ein bisschen anderes Klientel an. Und das sind dann junge Leute, die auch durchaus von weiter wegkommen. Also da haben wir dann ein größeres Einzugsgebiet und haben auch quasi ein spezialisierteres Angebot. Also wir haben mindestens an einem von beiden Terminen im Monat dann auch einen ordentlich organisierten Workshop, manchmal auch an beiden Terminen. Und ansonsten sind das halt offene Termine, wo die jungen Leute sich dann einfach treffen können und an eigenen Projekten arbeiten.
Dass jeder einen Schlüssel hat, ist die Grundlage. Aber hilft der Standort tatsächlich, damit die Jugendlichen nicht auf das Auto ihrer Eltern angewiesen sind?
Also wir profitieren insgesamt total viel von der Bahn. Das kann man gar nicht anders sagen, weil ja auch aus dem Norden, aus Neustrelitz junge Leute mit der Bahn kommen und wir auch Kransee als quasi nächste Station Richtung Süden irgendwie im Einzugsgebiet haben und einige unserer regelmäßigen Teilnehmer, Besucher, was auch immer, also von den Leuten, die sich diesen Platz, diesen Ort zu eigen machen, die kommen mit der Bahn. Aber es gibt halt auch ein paar, die wohnen so weit in der Pampa, dass sie entweder zu einer Bahn gebracht werden müssen oder gleich hergefahren werden. Und für Jugendhackt ist das, da sind wir zum Beispiel sehr stark auch für die Workshops angewiesen darauf, dass sich externe Mentoren quasi finden, ähnlich wie das ja für die Hackathons auch ist. Also wir sind immer auf der Suche nach Leuten, die spannende Projekte im Rahmen von einem Samstagsworkshop in bis zu fünf Stunden irgendwie hier anbieten wollen. Und für die ist es natürlich ganz besonders wichtig, dass wir mit dem Bahnhofsstandort, gerade aus Berlin raus, innerhalb von einer Stunde erreichbar sind. Also es ist denkbar einfach, sich an einem Samstagvormittag in Berlin in einen Zug zu setzen, hier raus zu fahren, von 12 bis 5 einen Workshop mit netten und total motivierten Jugendlichen machen und danach dann entweder wieder in die Stadt fahren oder eine Runde schwimmen gehen, ein bisschen im Wald spazieren, Fahrrad fahren oder was auch immer und halt einfach eine Nacht hier verbringen. Und das ist, glaube ich, auch unter dem Aspekt, dass wir angewiesen sind, trotzdem auch auf Dritte, die hierher kommen und mit uns gemeinsame Sachen machen. Wir sind einfach auch vor Ort hier noch nicht genug Leute, um alles abdecken zu können. Ist, glaube ich, dieser Standort in einem Bahnhof einfach halt total gut. Also von daher, wenn sich, wenn irgendjemand zuhört, der total motiviert ist, hier was zu machen, das steht immer offen und wir haben extrem dankbare Abnehmer und freuen uns über jeden, der Lust hat, uns ein bisschen zu unterstützen. Gleichzeitig haben wir mit Simon, der ja hier der Werkstattleiter ist quasi und die Jugendhackt-Lab-Koordination macht, auch jemanden, der fachlich total gut aufgestellt ist und sich darum kümmert, da ein richtig gutes Programm zu organisieren.
Doch damit das alles möglich war, musste der Verstehbahnhof erst seine Fläche erweitern. Die ursprüngliche Halle, mit der alles begann, war irgendwann nicht mehr genug.
Dann hat sich das Ergebnis, dass 2018 im zweiten Teil des Gebäudes, in dem eine Kneipe angesiedelt war und eine Wohnung, in der die Leute, die die Kneipe betrieben haben, gelebt haben, das wurde frei. Also die Bahnhofsgaststätte und die Wohnung oben drüber, da wurde der Mietvertrag aufgelöst und die sind ausgezogen. Und dann haben wir also quasi 2018 im Herbst einen mutigen Schritt gewagt als Verein und gesagt, wir mieten diese Bahnhofsgaststätte an, weil wir einfach feststellen, dass unser Projekt in der Halle, das wird angenommen, hier kommen junge Leute, die haben alle total Bock und es wird Zeit, das größer aufzustellen. Und dann haben wir diese Bahnhofsgaststätte angemietet mit knapp 250 Quadratmetern, haben in den größten Raum unsere Werkstatt reingebaut, haben den ehemaligen Automatenspielraum umgebaut als Wohnzimmer und haben die Bahnhofsgaststättenküche als Vereinsküche ausgebaut. Und weil es irgendwie wichtig war, dass auf dem Bahnhof trotzdem immer noch irgendwie so eine Art minimales gastronomisches Angebot stattfindet, haben wir Leute gefunden, die zwei Räume untergemietet haben und da heute den Ahoy-Shop, also das Ahoy-Café, betreiben. Das ist quasi das gemütlichste Bahnhof Bistro Deutschlands geworden, das ist wirklich richtig schick geworden, das passt auch alles hier total gut rein und wir haben da super kompatible Leute, die so eine gastronomische Grundversorgung sicherstellen.
Die Plätze vor dem Café sind, soweit coronabedingt möglich, gut gefüllt. In gemütlicher Atmosphäre gibt es belegte Brötchen, Kuchen und Kaffee. Von hier aus kriege ich eine kleine Tour. Der Verstehbahnhof verfügt mit der Veranstaltungshalle, der Werkstatt, in der wir das Interview aufzeichnen, dem Wohnzimmer und der Küche über vier allgemein nutzbare Räume.
Also seit zwei Monaten etwa gibt es jetzt ein Team von Leuten, die in der Volksküche starten wollen, in der Küche. Das ist jetzt auch der maßgebliche Treiber daran, dass die Renovierungsarbeiten oder die sind fertig, aber die Einrichtung der Küche gerade fertiggestellt wird und wir dann so jetzt Richtung Winter die ersten richtigen, also auch so unabhängige Kochsachen haben werden, wo Leute sich einfach zum Kochen dann gemeinsam treffen. Außerhalb von denen, die kochen, wenn sie mal in der Werkstatt sind oder so. Da ist der Eingang hier, das ist auch total gut, weil wir alles von außen auch zugänglich haben. Das liegt ja quasi direkt jetzt auf dem Weg vom Bahngleis, kommt man an der Küche vorbei. Wir haben gerade die erste Schrankfront hier aufgebaut und jetzt müssen wir noch diese Kochinsel, die wir hier eigentlich schon haben, von der dachten wir, das wäre das Richtige, aber wir tauschen das jetzt noch einmal ein bisschen aus gegen ein paar andere Möbel. Und dann muss noch mal ordentlich durchgeputzt werden. Hier wurden jetzt letzte Woche haben wir gerade die letzten Fliesen repariert auf dem Boden. Deswegen ist auch noch ein bisschen staubig und so Zementschleier hier drin. Aber das ist jetzt noch, ich würde mal sagen, vielleicht noch sechs oder acht Wochen irgendwie und dann sieht es hier drin richtig schick aus. Und dann kann hier gekocht werden und Leute können sich wieder auf ganz anderen Ebenen hier im Bahnhof begegnen und gemeinsam Dinge treiben.
Wir laufen nun weiter durch die Werkstatt, bis wir vor einer Verbindungstür stehen bleiben, die zur Veranstaltungshalle führt. Mit der hat alles angefangen.
Die Halle ist jetzt Corona bedingt, nutzen wir die Halle im Moment nicht. Das ist jetzt gerade erweitertes Wohnzimmer für die WG oben drüber, weil das einfach so, also von der Größe macht das keinen Sinn. Wenn jetzt irgendwas ist, im Winter, wir gucken bestimmt auch noch mal einen Film im Winter mit jungen Leuten oder sowas, da kann man da reingehen, aber ansonsten ist das jetzt eigentlich eher, versuchen wir das ein bisschen auf kleiner Flamme zu halten.
Daniel, öffnet die Tür.
Gucken nur mal rein. Also im Endeffekt, gerade ist das ein lauschiges Wohnzimmer, aber wir haben ja hier, wir haben so einen schönen Ofen in der Ecke stehen, den kann man dann im Winter irgendwie auch anmachen, so Bullerjahren irgendwie. Wir haben jetzt seit neuestem auch einen Holzboden hier unten drin. Hier sollen auch irgendwann Tanzveranstaltungen stattfinden, war so ein bisschen der Plan, dass jetzt hier sich auch so eine Tango-Truppe trifft. Es gibt jetzt für die, seit den Corona-Monaten hier drin, so eine gewisse improvisierte Sportsituation, wo man sich ein bisschen körperlich ausleben kann. Ansonsten ist das hier so ein bisschen Heimarbeitsplatz gerade, Homeoffice. Es gibt Musik, es ist relativ hell jetzt hier drin, das ist eigentlich auch gerade ganz angenehm. Aber wir haben halt keine Tische aufgebaut, oder die Bühne haben wir rausgetragen, die ist gerade im Keller eingelagert. Also ist halt sehr viel, also eigentlich alles hier insgesamt so sehr flexibel. Und wir können dann immer nach Bedarf eigentlich gerade aus dem Keller was hochtragen, aufbauen oder wie auch immer. Und das funktioniert so ganz gut, glaube ich, so als Gesamtkonzept.
Auf dem Weg zum Wohnzimmer kommen wir an einem bis zur Decke gefüllten Regalaufbau vorbei.
Hier ist unsere Lagersituation. Wir sind große Freunde von DIN-Kisten. Also wir hatten ja mal überlegt, was ist die beste Kistenform. Dann haben wir überlegt, machen wir das auch mit diesen Postschwingen oder so. Aber im Endeffekt ist das jetzt auf diese grauen DIN-Kisten rausgelaufen. Man sieht, wir versuchen das alles ordentlich zu labeln. Wir haben ein Farbsystem etabliert, das für die Kids klar ist, wo können sie sich einfach bedienen und wo müssen sie fragen, um das alles möglichst autonom zu halten. Hier drüben ist unsere Fischertechnik-Sammlung. Die Städte sind gerade etwas undankbar in der Ecke. Da müssen wir uns noch überlegen, wie wir diese Schüttkisten am besten organisieren. Aber wir haben ja auch eine sehr ausgebaute Fischertechnik-Sammlung, sodass man gerade für Mikrocontrollergeschichten, mit dem Calliope Mini zum Beispiel, ist das super. Dann kann ich Fahrzeuge bauen oder eine Smart City Situation überlegen und kann das dann alles ansteuern über den Calliope Mini. Dann hat man da gleich so eine total gute Schnittstellen zwischen, ich bastel was und kann das aber programmieren. Ich kann vielleicht noch ein bisschen was über Mechanik verstehen dabei oder irgendwie diese ganze Physikkomponente noch mit reinbringen. Das funktioniert eigentlich auch gut und macht halt Spaß. Es sind dann immer viele Querschnittsthemen.
Wir durchschreiten einen weiteren Türrahmen und stehen im Wohnzimmer. Vor einer brusthohen, holzvertäfelten Wand stehen Sessel, Couches und Lampen. Der Raum strahlt einen gemütlichen Retro-Look aus.
Eigentlich ist das so, finde ich, fast der charmanteste Raum. Die Werkstatt ist ja so ein bisschen sehr funktional eingerichtet. Wir sind in einem denkmalgeschützten Gebäude hier und haben ganz viele Auflagen bekommen, wie wir hier sanieren müssten. Und dann haben wir hier diesen Putz, der hier drin war in dem Wohnzimmer, den haben wir runtergemacht und dann festgestellt, dass hinten dran eigentlich das eigentliche Denkmal verborgen ist. Also diese Wände, die es jetzt hier gibt, mit mindestens zehn verschiedenen Farben, die in so einer total schönen Patina eigentlich sich da an der Wand befinden und die ganz viel erzählen über unterschiedliche Zeitpunkte, in denen dieser Raum unterschiedliche Eigentümer oder Nutzungszwecke hatte, in unterschiedlichen Farben gestrichen war oder so. Und dann haben wir uns entschieden, das nicht wie der Denkmalschützer es wollte grau anzumalen, sondern das einfach so zu lassen, in so einem unrestaurierten Zustand. Wir haben hier unten so eine Holzbordüre. Die haben wir jetzt auch quasi freigekratzt. Und die Optik gefällt uns eigentlich ganz gut. Und dann der Rest sind irgendwie Möbel, die entweder Leute wobeigebracht haben, oder die wir irgendwo auch wieder bei eBay-Kleinanzeigen gefunden haben. Also so ein bisschen auf alt getrimmt. Und dann natürlich darf man überhaupt nicht vergessen, der Ledersessel, der sich in dieser Ecke befindet. Ein Urgestein aus der Marienstraße, der gerettet wurde. Ebenso wie der runde Tisch, der hier steht. Also die haben viel gesehen und erlebt. Und von daher sind wir total froh. Das hatte sich auf dem Camp in Mildenberg ergeben beim letzten Mal, dass die nicht wieder mit zurück nach Berlin sollten. Und wir fühlen uns wirklich sehr geehrt, dass die hier gelandet sind, weil wir damit was weitertragen. Also vor einem undankbaren Tod gerettet haben und gleichzeitig Leute total gerne da drin sitzen. Also der ist mindestens so gemütlich wie ja alles, dieser Sessel. Also das ist total gut.
Mir scheint, dass das Verstehbahnhof-Team einen ziemlich einzigartigen Ort aufgebaut hat. Nun interessiert mich allerdings, wie die Fürstenberger ihren Space aufnehmen.
Das wird total gut angenommen. Also wir hier in der Werkstatt E wir sind hier in einer Kleinstadt. Das ist ein bisschen das, was wir uns erhofft haben, 4.500 Einwohner oder sowas in dieser Kernstadt. Hier kennt man mehr oder weniger jeden. Wir sind hier relativ überregional bekannt, weil wir halt was ganz anderes machen. Das wurde vielleicht am Anfang auch ein bisschen skeptisch betrachtet. Aber im Endeffekt ist es so, dass wir für junge Leute hier total, also unbestreitbar sinnvolle Perspektiven bieten. Hier kann man Dinge lernen, hier kann man sich selber helfen, hier gibt es einen Repair-Café, wo man irgendwie sein Haushaltsgerät repariert oder repariert bekommen kann. Das sind alle möglichen Dinge, die rund um diese Werkstatt passieren, wo es sehr schwer wäre, glaube ich, Gründe zu finden, warum das jetzt irgendwie schlecht ist oder man das irgendwie doof findet. Und jeder in der Stadt hier kennt entweder, also hat Kinder oder hat Enkel oder kennt irgendwelche Kinder, an denen ihm oder ihr was liegt. Und damit ist dieses Projekt hier, glaube ich, hat das einfach einen ganz guten Status. Und gleichzeitig haben wir in Fürstenberg hier keinerlei quasi gemeinnützige Infrastruktur in dem Sinne. Also es gibt kein Familienzentrum oder Nachbarschaftshaus oder alle diese sozialen Orte, die in Städten total selbstverständlich sind, die gibt es hier eben auch nicht. Und wenn man jetzt guckt, es gibt so eine Selbsthilfegruppe, es gibt so eine kleine Behindertengruppe, also Rollstuhlfahrer, die sich irgendwie treffen regelmäßig. Die haben immer nur die Wahl, sich entweder privat bei irgendjemandem zu treffen oder sich halt in irgendwie in eine Kneipe oder ein Restaurant zu setzen. Und das wiederum kommt mit einer sozialen Sanktion irgendwie, dann kostet das gleich was. Oder es ist privat und damit nicht so richtig offen und einladend. Und die treffen sich mittlerweile in unserem Wohnzimmer. Also wir haben schon längst so eine Nutzung dieses Ortes hier durch Leute, die mit der Werkstatt und dem Hackspace oder was auch immer überhaupt nichts zu tun haben, die dann aber gleichzeitig feststellen, dass im Raum nebenan irgendwie junge Leute sind, die sich mit technischen Themen auseinandersetzen, die an irgendwelchen verrückten Projekten arbeiten oder so. Und so gibt es einen Austausch, der sonst auch gar nicht stattfinden würde. Und ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen vielleicht auch das, womit man einfach rechnen muss, wenn man rauszieht in eine Kleinstadt oder aufs Land. Und ich halte das auch für einen riesigen Vorteil, dass man sich eben rausbegibt aus dieser Filterblase, wo man jetzt wie in Berlin oder in einer anderen Stadt sein ganzes Leben verbringen kann in irgendwie der Gruppe von Leuten, die sich für die gleichen Themen interessieren und die politisch ähnlich irgendwie alles sehen. Das hat auch Vorteile. Aber gleichzeitig lebt man halt auch oft in einem Haus, von dem man gar nicht wirklich weiß, wer da sonst noch lebt. Und mit einem sehr hohen Grad an Anonymität. Und das gibt es hier so nicht. Das ist hier alles sehr direkt. Ich kenne meine Nachbarn. Ich kenne eigentlich fast alle Leute, die in der ganzen Straße leben. Und irgendwie sonst so im Stadtbild unterwegs sind. Und die wissen, was ich mache. Und so kann man sich auch gegenseitig unterstützen. Oder man kann sich gegenseitig ansprechen, wenn man irgendwie den Eindruck hat, ich brauche mal Unterstützung mit meinem Computer. Ich hatte das auch ganz am Anfang. Es gibt so einen Fleischerwagen, der hier einmal in der Woche kommt. Der Metzger hält dann mit so einem Auto irgendwo. Und dann hat man zwei Stunden Zeit, sich da ein bisschen was zum Grillen abzuholen oder so. Und da stand ich halt irgendwann so im ersten Jahr, dass wir hier waren, da in dieser Warteschlange vorne dran. Und dann hat mich einer angequatschte hinter mir stand und wollte irgendwie wissen, ob ich mal bei ihm vorbeikommen könnte, um seinen Computer zu reparieren, weil er gehört hat, dass ich irgendwie was mit Computern mache. Und das war total schön irgendwie so als, also so als Erfahrung, dass man sich halt gegenseitig irgendwie unterstützt. Und wir haben diese Erfahrung, dass wir Leute unterstützen und haben gleichzeitig aber auch sehr viel Feedback, wo wir Sachen angeboten bekommen. Wo Leute sagen, wir finden das, was ihr macht, halt total gut. Es gab so eine total schöne Begegnung im letzten Jahr. Wir haben, oder in diesem Jahr war das, wir haben hier für in der Corona-Zeit, genau wie die anderen Werkstätten auch irgendwie Visiere produziert. Und dann kam hier einer aus der Stadt vorbei, der für seine zwei Töchter, die Medizin studieren und irgendwie in der Klinik arbeiten gerade, der wissen wollte, ob er da so ein paar Visiere haben kann. Und seitdem haben wir eine Honigflatrate, weil der hat wiederum ziemlich viele Bienen. Und versorgt uns jetzt mit Honig irgendwie. Und das ist so ein direktes Ding, was einfach ganz anders läuft, als das in der Stadt der Fall ist. Und dementsprechend, um nochmal darauf zurückzukommen, das wird alles total gut angenommen und es funktioniert. Und wir hatten uns mit dem Einzug in unsere neuen Räumlichkeiten so einen 3-Jahreszeitraum gesteckt. Also bis Ende 2021. Indem wir dann evaluieren wollten, ob das funktioniert und ob wir als Verein mit diesen Räumen uns entweder komplett verschätzt haben und das halt nicht weiter funktioniert. Oder ob das alles irgendwie aufgeht. Und ich glaube, man kann komplett zweifelsfrei sagen, dass das halt eine richtig gute Entscheidung war.
Auch Erwachsene engagieren sich im Verstehbahnhof. Vor allem die, die vorher schon technisch alfin waren. Doch dabei ist es nicht geblieben.
Also wir haben in der Tat auch ein paar Erwachsene, die sich hier treffen. Also erstmal haben wir festgestellt, dass hier in dieser ganzen Gegend lauter Leute wohnen, von denen wir gar nichts wussten. Also hier die Straße runter wohnt ein echt populärer, iOS-Entwickler, den irgendwie fast jeder kennt, ist mein Eindruck, weil der Schulungsvideos zum Programmieren mit iOS macht. Oder Swift, genau genommen. Der kam irgendwann hier vorbei und fand das auch total gut. Und da haben wir festgestellt, der lebt hier um die Ecke. Das hätten wir so gar nicht gewusst. Und der hilft halt auch ein bisschen mit. Dann gibt es hier so einen pensionierten Elektriker, der total Arduino-affin ist und zu Hause halt irgendwie Projekte bastelt für sich und für seine Enkel irgendwie. Der kommt halt auch regelmäßig und macht hier mit uns irgendwelche Dinge. Und genauso haben wir festgestellt, dass hier eine Vielzahl anderer Leute sind, die eine Affinität haben für das, was wir hier machen und sich hier mit einbringen und das irgendwie unterstützen. Und dann gibt es natürlich einen Haufen Leute, die sich mit diesen ganzen Themen überhaupt nicht beschäftigen, die aber natürlich alle schon was davon gehört haben. Also gerade so das Thema 3D-Druck ist so ein stereotypes Beispiel irgendwie. Alle haben schon mal von 3D-Druck gehört, aber die meisten hier haben es noch nie gesehen. Und so ist es schon so, dass es so neugierige Leute gibt, die dann einfach, wir sind ja hier zentral am Bahnhof, einfach mal reinkommen, wenn die Tür auf ist. Und dann sagen, wir haben gehört, hier gibt es so 3D-Drucker, das wollte ich schon immer mal sehen irgendwie. Und dann unterhält man sich halt mal eine halbe Stunde oder so mit denen. Und zeigt denen was oder zeigt denen die Maschinen, druckt mal was oder so. Und genau das Gleiche gilt eigentlich für die anderen Sachen, die wir hier auch haben. Wir haben ja quasi einmal so eine Ausstattung für, das gibt die ganze Desktop Fabrication-Palette eines Makerspaces. 3D-Drucker, Transferpresse, Schneideplotter, Lasercutter, Elektronikwerkstatt und so. Und da gibt es ganz viele Sachen, wo unterschiedliche Leute gehört haben, dass es das gibt. Und dafür eine ganz unterschiedliche Vorstellung haben, für was sie das gerne mal nutzen würden. Also von Eltern, die T-Shirts designen wollen für ihre Kinder, über Leute, die irgendwas gravieren wollen, offen Laser, über die 3D-Druckfraktionen, die schon immer mal wissen wollte oder sehen wollte, wie sowas funktioniert. Und das ist eigentlich auch ziemlich gut. Ich hoffe, dass wir so über Zeit, das ist eines unserer perspektivischen Ziele, eben auch dazu beitragen können, dass wir einen höheren Grad so an Grundkompetenz zum Thema Digitalisierung haben. Dass das hier einfach einen Ort gibt, wo man Fragen stellen kann, wo man Dinge erleben kann und wo man vielleicht Antworten auf ein paar dieser größeren Themen findet oder in der Lage ist, bestimmte Themen einfach auch ein bisschen besser einzusortieren. Das ganze Thema Breitbandausbau zum Beispiel ist so ein typisches Thema. Das wird eine riesige Rolle spielen für uns hier in Fürstenberg, wie dieser Breitbandausbau gestaltet wird in Zukunft und dass der überhaupt stattfindet. Und die Infrastruktur vorhanden ist, aber auch Fragen natürlich, wie ist die zugänglich, wer entscheidet darüber, was hier verbaut wird, wie das in Zukunft irgendwie nutzbar wird. Und das sind total abstrakte Themen für alle Leute, die nicht aus unserer Filterblase irgendwie kommen, die sich mit sowas ständig beschäftigen, die wissen, was Netzneutralität ist und warum das irgendwie wichtig ist. Das ist ganz abstrakt und überhaupt nicht nachvollziehbar. Und das braucht so einen Ort, wo man sich zu solchen Themen austauschen kann und wo man so eine haptische Erfahrung vielleicht haben kann damit, damit man dieses Thema erstmal setzen kann, damit Leute anfangen, drüber nachzudenken und man sich dann mit so einer Kleinstadt auf den Weg macht, dass man quasi immer tiefer vielleicht auch in solche Themen eintauchen kann.
Auch Infrastruktur ist dem Verstehbahnhof-Team wichtig. Der Verstehbahnhof ist einer der wenigen Hacker-Spaces mit einer direkten Glasfaseranbindung in ein Rechenzentrum. Ich frage Daniel, wie es dazu gekommen ist. Wer muss erst mal auswollen?
Als wir hier rausgezogen sind, war klar, dass es irgendwie... Wir sind hier im Telekom-Gebiet. Die Telekom hat hier in den letzten Jahren VDSL ausgerollt. Zumindest in der Kernstadt, in den Ortsteilen, die zu Fürstenberg gehört, sieht das noch ein bisschen anders aus. Aber damit war die Versorgung ganz gut. Es gibt hier ein LTE-Netz. Man lebt auf diesem deutschen Durchschnittsstandard. Oder dem, was in Deutschland gerade der Breitbandausbau ist. Gleichzeitig gab es immer, genau wie wir davon geträumt haben, vielleicht irgendwann diesen Makerspace hier mal zu haben, haben wir total lustig. Wir sind 2011 hier raus. 2013 habe ich das erste Mal mit Leuten im Keller gestanden und denen gesagt, dass ich irgendwann in diesen einen Kellerraum ein Rechenzentrum einbauen will. Mittlerweile hatte ich das schon längst vergessen. Aber ich hatte letztens Besuch von jemandem, der seit vielen Jahren nicht mehr da war. Und der hat gesagt, ich habe damals zu ihm gesagt, hier will ich ein Rechenzentrum reinbauen. Und er hat gedacht, ich habe einen totalen Sockenschuss irgendwie. Und jetzt hat sich das über das zweite Thema Bildung und Infrastruktur, das zweite Thema, was es braucht, damit das langfristig hier funktioniert. Und so haben wir die letzten Jahre eigentlich immer irgendwie überlegt, wie könnte man hier eine andere Anbindung kriegen? Also auch eine größere Unabhängigkeit. Ich hatte ja mal mit Anke gemeinsam irgendwie so ein kleines Start-up gegründet. Und wir haben versucht, so diese Idee vom skandinavischen Ausbaumodell irgendwie hier in Deutschland zu platzieren. Das hat dann eine Zeit lang die totale Welle gemacht, aber im Endeffekt hat das nirgends funktioniert. Das ist einfach, wir haben, ich weiß gar nicht, wie viele Termine wir hatten mit Bürgermeistern, auch mit dem Bürgermeister hier, mit der Regionalentwicklung und so. Die sagen alle, ah ja super. Aber im Endeffekt hoffen dann doch alle, dass es die Telekom irgendwie übernimmt oder irgendjemand ihnen das abnimmt. Und das hat wieder mit dem zu tun, was ich gerade gesagt hatte. Es ist so abstrakt und niemand, oder wenige Leute, die in der Verwaltung sitzen und jetzt die Technik nicht verstehen, trauen sich, sich auf was einzulassen, wobei sie sich auch total irren könnten. Und ich glaube, das ist eine der größten Hemmschwellen, die wir haben, was den Breitbandausbau angeht, dass wir so generell eine schlechte Bildung haben zu diesem ganzen Thema, warum das wichtig wäre, warum es wichtig ist, dass das ein neutrales Netz ist, warum das Gespräch über das Trägermedium wichtig ist, warum man nicht paternalistisch von irgendwem gesagt bekommen möchte, wie viel Embed jeder braucht oder so, sondern dass das perspektivisch in Zukunft eine ganz andere Sicht braucht. Und dieses Gespräch wird so wenig geführt und auch nicht in der Breite geführt, dass wir in einem Land leben, das voller Bürgermeister ist, die das nicht richtig einschätzen können und voller Verwalter und Stadtvorordneter und so, die eine Berührungsangst haben und deswegen hoffen, dass ihnen diese Entscheidung irgendjemand anders abnimmt. Na ja, und so hat sich das hier irgendwie so ein bisschen erledigt mit der Stadt am Anfang. Wir haben es nicht geschafft, irgendjemandem zu überzeugen, dass ein städtisch getriebener Glasfaserausbau das Beste und das Sinnvollste ist, was die Stadt irgendwie machen könnte. Wir haben aber gleichzeitig immer irgendwie überlegt, was gibt es hier für andere Möglichkeiten. Und jetzt leben wir direkt am Bahnhof. In der Bahntrasse liegt auch eine Glasfasertrasse. Ich habe dann vor drei Jahren oder so, glaube ich, mal mit der Bahn gesprochen und versucht herauszufinden, wie man an diese Trasse angeschlossen werden könnte und dann festgestellt, dass das ein sehr leidiger Prozess ist. Das kostet alleine die Erhebung. Festzustellen, ob in dieser Trasse noch Platz ist, ist schon prohibitiv teuer, eigentlich, weil da jede Muffe kontrolliert wird. Zumindest wurde mir das von der DB Netze so erklärt. Da muss also einer quasi die ganze Strecke kontrollieren und gucken, ob auf der ganzen Strecke, die ich haben will, irgendwie Platz ist. Das ist ein Kostenposten, der in so einem mittleren bis hohen vierstelligen Eurobetrag liegt, nur um herauszufinden, ob ich überhaupt eine Verhandlungsgrundlage hätte. Das haben wir halt nicht gemacht. Und dann hat sich aber 2000, ich weiß gar nicht, wann war das, auch vor drei Jahren oder sowas, gab es so die ersten Gerüchte, dass eine neue Trasse gebaut werden soll, die verschiedene Hyperscaler-Rechenzentren in Skandinavien besser anbinden soll an Berlin. Und dann habe ich dann natürlich irgendwie die Augen und die Ohren offen gehalten. Wir haben versucht rauszufinden, wer das baut, wie das läuft. Dann wussten wir irgendwann, dass das eine gemeinsame Unternehmung von zwei Unternehmen ist, die Gasline und die Global Connect. Dann habe ich angefangen, versucht irgendwelche Kontakte zu kriegen, habe jemanden total netten bei der Global Connect kennengelernt, der, glaube ich, versteht, dass das, was wir hier vorhaben, eine ganz gute Sache ist, der das unterstützt hat, der uns so ein bisschen auf den Laufenden gehalten hat. Und dann total irrwitzig, und das ist auch so ein deutsches Problem, die haben mit dem Ausbau ihrer Trasse sind die im totalen Genehmigungsdschungel gelandet. Das ist dann auf so einem Level, weiß nicht, ob das auch allen so bewusst ist, aber wenn man jetzt von Rostock oder Stralsund bis Berlin eine Trasse bauen will, hat man mit hunderten unterschiedlichen Genehmigungsteilnehmern zu tun. Dann gibt es manchmal Forstbehörden, bei denen sind das 300 Meter oder so, aber die haben überhaupt keine Lust, den Antrag zu bearbeiten, und das dauert ewig. Und so hat sich diese ganze Trasse, also zum einen hatte sich dieses Projekt irgendwie stark verzögert, und das Projekt musste ständig neu geplant werden, weil gewisse Teilbereiche irgendwie nicht so genehmigt werden konnten, wie das mal geplant war. Und hier in Fürstenberg sollte die Trasse eigentlich entlang der Hauptstraße laufen, und das wäre halt so 300 Meter an der falschen Ecke gewesen. Und ich hab mich total geärgert, und irgendwann kam so ein Anruf, und die sagten, die Trassenplanung musste geändert werden wegen so einem Genehmigungsproblem, und es könnte sein, dass das jetzt hier direkt bei uns vorbeikommt. Und so hat sich das dann echt ergeben, dass genau zwischen diesen beiden Häusern unserem Haus und dem Bahnhof quasi die Trasse gebohrt wurde. Von diesem Tag, an dem Jürgen bei Global Connect uns gesagt hat, dass die Trasse hier gebaut wird, bis zu dem Tag, dass als der Horizontalbohrzug auf einmal vor der Tür stand, vergingen keine zwei Wochen. Ich stand morgens in der Küche, guck aus dem Fenster, und dann kam da erst so was, was schwer nach einem Horizontalbohrfahrzeug aussah. Dann kam noch so ein kleiner Bagger dazu, und dann kam so ein Spülwagen, so ein großer. Und dann hab ich gedacht, okay, also die sind jetzt echt da. Dann war dieser Projektmanager aber noch im Urlaub. Dann haben wir überlegt, was machen wir jetzt? Und dann bin ich einfach raus. Und dann hab ich die an der Baustelle angequatscht und hab ihn gefragt, wie ist der Zeitplan? Dann haben die gesagt, wir sind drei Tage hier. Und dann hab ich gesagt, okay, ich muss in diesen drei Tagen klären, dass wir hier mit angeschlossen werden. Ja, das ist halt alles nicht geplant. Und wie auch immer, dann haben wir da so ein bisschen hin und her verhandelt. Ich hab den ganzen Tag Kaffee gekocht, hab den Mittagsmittagessen gekocht, hab alles gemacht, um mich gut mit der Baustellencrew zu stellen. Und in der Tat haben wir in drei Tagen dann irgendwie so kurzfristig rausgehandelt, dass hier ein Schacht gesetzt wird. Und ich hab denen quasi noch so einen Mini-Auftrag gegeben. Und die haben die Horizontalbohrung zu uns ans Haus gemacht. Und so sind wir dann auf einmal innerhalb von ein paar Tagen mit einem eigenen Leerrohr an den Schacht angeschlossen gewesen, der eigentlich halt irgendwie zwei geografische Regionen miteinander verbindet. Also wir sind jetzt angeschlossen an einen Teil des Internetbackbones. Und damit sind wir in dieser total luxuriösen Situation. Na, das war auch so ein Ding, die sagten dann, wenn wir hier fertig sind, kommt die Truppe, die das alles einbläst. Die kommen in fünf Tagen oder so. Dachte ich, jetzt müssen wir irgendwie schnell Glasfaser auftreiben, damit falls die hier auftauchen, wir das direkt mit einblasen lassen können. Dann habe ich geguckt, wer ist hier in der Nähe, habe nur so einen Laden gefunden in Telto-Fleming, die einblasfähige Glasfaser auch auf Lager haben. Dann bin ich dahin gefahren, habe denen gesagt, ich brauche irgendwie 80 Meter. Dann haben die mich angeguckt und gesagt, da können wir jetzt höchstens suchen, ob wir einen Kabelrest haben. Der einzige Kabelrest, den die hatten, das war eine Faser mit 144 Fasern, was auch ein bisschen überdimensioniert ist eigentlich. So haben wir jetzt aber 144 Fasern zu dieser Trasse liegen. In der Trasse selbst sind irgendwie 4x288 Fasern drin. Wir haben potenziell gigantische Bandbreiten, die sich hier auftun. Das bedeutet im Endeffekt, also ich könnte wahrscheinlich, wenn alle Häuser des Landkreises eine Verbindung hätten zu mir hier, könnte ich die alle versorgen. Das würde niemals nicht skalieren. Und so hatten wir vor drei Jahren jetzt auf einmal diese Perspektive auf einen Anschluss, nicht an irgendwie ein Breitbandnetz in dem Sinne, sondern an den Backbone irgendwie. Und dann haben wir gesagt, okay, das ist ja jetzt, das wird jetzt irgendwie gerade ernst. Müssen wir uns ein paar Gedanken machen. Und dann haben wir angefangen, unten im Keller einen Raum auszubauen als Rechenzentrum. Und das ist dann auch ein Projekt, was wir wieder mit den jungen Leuten gemacht haben. Also wir haben, dazu muss man jetzt sagen, wir haben sowas schon ein paar Mal gemacht. Also wir haben in der Vergangenheit in so kleineren Standorten Rechenzentren aufgebaut, in so einem kleinen Bürostandort, mal in so einer Büroetage, wo das jemand gerne quasi für Kunden vorzeigbar haben wollte. Wir haben ja auch in anderen Ländern hier ein bisschen Infrastruktur aufgebaut. Und wir haben darüber eigentlich die letzten Jahre oder Jahrzehnte alles mögliche so ein Werkzeug beschafft. Also bis zum allem, was wir brauchen, um unsere eigenen Fasern zu schleißen und mit der Lupe auf die Enden gucken zu können. Und so ist einfach alles da. Und wir haben dann gesagt, okay, wir bauen diesen Raum halt einmal komplett selbst. Wir haben Estrich gießen lassen. Das war so das letzte, was jemand anders gemacht hat. Und dann haben wir überlegt, was brauchen wir sonst noch? Und dann ging es los auf eBay-Kleinanzeigen eigentlich. Und wir hatten tierisches Glück. Wir hatten immer so den Traum von einem energieeffizienten Rechenzentrum und haben dann in der Tat echt bei eBay-Kleinanzeigen Schränke inklusive der Wärmetauschertüren von IBM gefunden, die aus dem Höchstleistungsrechenzentrum Stuttgart ausgebaut waren und bei eBay-Kleinanzeigen aufgetaucht sind. Und da haben wir uns sechs Schränke inklusive der Türen gekauft, die vollkommen unbezahlbar wären für uns, zu einem Preis, der, also es ist einfach ein Witz gewesen irgendwie, es war total machbar. Und dann haben wir diese Wärmetauschertüren, dann haben wir uns überlegt, okay, wir brauchen eigentlich einen Doppelboden, damit wir die Verrohrung von unten machen können. Dann ist irgendwie ein paar Wochen später auf eBay-Kleinanzeigen hier so eine Studioauflösung um die Ecke aufgetaucht, wo zweieinhalbtausend oder dreitausend Bodenplatten für einen Doppelboden verschenkt wurden. Dann habe ich da angerufen, die haben gesagt, wir sollen das einfach abholen. Das war natürlich alles irgendwie palettiert und viel zu schwer. Dann habe ich festgestellt, die sitzen direkt neben der Spedition, bei der Spedition angerufen. Dann haben die das irgendwo so mit eingetaktet. Wir hatten es ja jetzt auch nicht eilig. Und wir haben für ein Appel und ein Ei palettenweise Bodenplatten geliefert bekommen, die wir dann im Keller verbaut haben. So haben wir uns den doppelten Boden eingebaut. Dann haben wir ein bisschen Trockenbau gemacht, haben das irgendwie alles schick gemacht, haben Kabeltrassen verbaut, die ganze Netzwerk, also Kupfer- und Glasverkabelung irgendwie zu den Schränken gemacht, uns einen Patch-Schrank aufgebaut. Und jetzt haben wir halt ein Rechenzentrum im Keller mit sechs Schränken, von denen einer nur gedacht ist, als Spielwiese hier für den Bahnhof, wo junge Leute irgendwie ihren Kram hosten können, wo die ganzen Kids, die programmieren lernen, in der Lage sind auch zu verstehen, dass es Infrastruktur unten drunter gibt, auf der das dann ja auch laufen muss, die man auch anfassen kann, die man selber verkabeln kann, die man verstehen kann. Wir haben einen Schrank, den wir so für regionale Entwicklungen benutzen wollen, also die Fürstenberg Cloud und Infrastruktur für Vereine, für Leute und was uns halt gerade alles noch so einfällt, das geht jetzt gerade los. Und wir haben drei Schränke, in die wir im Endeffekt sympathische Projekte unterbringen können. Und wir sind angebunden mit 10 Gigabit im Moment. Das ist total ausreichend. Und wir haben also so Größenordnung 100 aufwärts, Höheneinheiten, die wir zur Verfügung stellen können, für Leute, die sagen, dass das hier, was wir machen, irgendwie sinnvoll ist und die mithelfen, das einfach so zu gegenfinanzieren, dass es im Endeffekt halt einfach eine schwarze Null ist, die total viele Möglichkeiten für uns hier bietet und helfen kann an diesem Ort. Und darauf läuft das jetzt mit all diesen Komponenten, über die wir gerade gesprochen haben, hinaus, dass wir einfach eine echt umfangreiche Spielwiese haben, auf der wir in einer ganz anderen Lage sind, als irgendwo anders meines Wissens nach zu überlegen, wie man Digitalisierung hier vor Ort einfach mal macht. Und zwar unabhängig von Unternehmen, unabhängig von der Stadt, sondern getrieben aus einer kleinen und wachsenden Community von Leuten aus unserer Filterblase. Und wie sich das dann auswirkt auf so eine Stadt.
Nun bin ich neugierig auf Daniels kleines Rechenzentrum. Das befindet sich in seinem Haus, auf der anderen Seite des Bahnhofsvorplatzes. Wir gehen hin.
Gerade ist es viel lauter als eigentlich, weil wir mit so einer Turbine die Warmenluft aus dem Raum rausziehen und in den Keller verteilen. Das wird so lange, bis draußen zwei Brunnen gebohrt sind, die uns Kaltwasser geben als Wärmewärmepumpe für das Rechenzentrum. Dann ist das im Moment noch etwas improvisiert. Wir haben insgesamt, glaube ich, hier so eine ganz interessante Ästhetik geschaffen. Mit unserem Pyramidenschaumstoff an den Wänden, der auch das Arbeiten hier unten ein bisschen angenehmer macht von der Akustik. So über unsere Oma-Steelampen, die wir hier so überall haben, um unser RZ zu beleuchten, ist das dann so eine ganz gute, glaube ich, ganz wohlige Atmosphäre. Wir halten uns ja hier auch gerne auf. Ich glaube, Teil der ganzen Angelegenheit ist nicht, dass wir hier einen Raum schaffen wollten, in dem man keiner sein will, sondern wir fühlen uns ja auch wohl hier unten. Dann kann man auch hier vor Ort arbeiten und Dinge tun. Das ist ganz gut.
Damit man im Serverraum allerdings vernünftig arbeiten kann, muss das Gebläse weg. Für die Kühlung sorgen künftig die Serverschränke selbst.
Im Endeffekt haben wir in den Türen hinten drin diesen Wärmetauscher, der dann, wenn die quasi von vorne im Rack die Luft angezogen wird, um dann durch den Server durchgeblasen werden, kommt hinten die warme Luft hier raus und die wird dann gleich über diesen Wärmetauscher geblasen und runtergekühlt. Und so haben wir dann in Zukunft eigentlich nur dieses Stück zwischen Ausgang aus dem Servergehäuse bis zur hinteren Tür, in der wirklich warme Luft anfällt. Und das, was dann aus der Tür hinten rauskommt, ist schon wieder auf Raumtemperatur. Und über so einen Wasserkreislauf wird das dann in den Raum nebenan geschafft, das bauen wir jetzt gerade. Da gibt es dann so einen Schichtspeicher, in dem wir dann quasi unten kaltes Wasser haben und oben das warme Wasser. Und dann können wir das warme Wasser oben zum Beispiel für Fußbodenheizung hier im Haus gebrauchen oder irgendwo anders sinnvoll einsetzen. Und gleichzeitig haben wir unten kaltes Wasser, was wir nutzen können, um die Server hier mit dem Vorlauf runter zu kühlen.
Das kleine Rechenzentrum versucht dabei nicht, in den Wettbewerb mit großen Anbietern zu gehen. Allerdings bietet die Region auch für diese Chancen.
Es ist allerdings auch so, dass es ein anderes Grundstück hier um die Ecke gibt und es auch ernsthafte Überlegungen gibt, ob man da nicht noch ein etwas größeres Rechenzentrum baut mit ein paar tausend Quadratmetern. Rechenzentren haben in Berlin ja das gleiche Problem wie die Wohnungen. Das ist einfach teurer Real Estate. Wenn man sich mit einem Betreiber aus Berlin zusammentun würde, um hier gemeinsam was aufzubauen, dann gäbe es hier was, was trotzdem eine ordentliche Anbindung hat, auch über drei oder vier verschiedene Beine, die wir hier gewährleisten könnten. Gleichzeitig wäre es halt wie auch der Wohnraum in der Gegend, in der die Quadratmeter nicht so teuer sind, wie irgendwo in der Stadt.
Auf dem Twitter-Account des Verstehbarenhofs habe ich gesehen, dass sich Flüchtlinge aus Syrien im Verstehbarenhof engagieren. Auch beim Aufbau des Rechenzentrums haben sie geholfen. Daniel erklärt, warum.
Wir sind ja hier auch personell sehr eng verwoben mit unserer Geflüchteteninitiative. Wir hatten bei uns im Haus ja auch sehr viele Geflüchtete, die wir temporär quasi untergebracht haben. Und damit sind wir auch in diese ganze Gemeinschaft total gut vernetzt. Und das ist einfach auch was, was ich glaube, was mir die letzten Jahre einfach auch aufgefallen. Für all die Kinder mit Migrationshintergrund ist das hier nochmal eine ganz andere Relevanz. Weil wir, ähnlich wie bei deutschen bildungsfernen Familien oder bei Familien, denen der Zugang zu Bildung auch aufgrund der Sprachbarriere einfach schwer fällt, wir in der Lage sind, Kompetenzen hier zu vermitteln, die für die Zukunft total relevant sind. Und das ist dann ja entweder eine Zukunft hier in Deutschland, aber genauso für den Fall, dass die irgendwann vielleicht, wenn der Krieg in Syrien vorbei ist, wieder zurück in Syrien, sind das, also ob das jetzt Programmieren ist oder mit uns gemeinsam drüben Fasern im Rechenzentrum gespleißt zu haben, das sind Kompetenzen, die total wichtig sind, wenn man ein Land, das komplett in Schutt und Asche liegt, irgendwie wieder aufbauen möchte. Und wenn man vielleicht eine Perspektive hat, warum solche Kompetenzen wichtig sind und wie man sich damit selber helfen kann, wie man Zugang wieder zu anderem Wissen findet und einfach Lösungen schafft. Und wenn das nur so das algorithmische Denken ist, dass man das einem sicherlich auch dabei helfen kann, ein Land wieder aufzubauen. Wenn man das einfach ein bisschen strukturiert versteht, das strukturierter anzugehen und zu betrachten.
Dass sie etwas aufbauen können, haben die Mitglieder des Verstehbahnhofs eindrucksvoll bewiesen. Doch wie soll es weitergehen?
Also für mich und ich glaube für uns alle hier eigentlich ist das, was wir bisher gemacht haben, nur die Bereitung einer Grundlage gewesen. Also wir haben hier die Werkstatt und in dieser Werkstatt können wir Dinge bauen. Wir können hier nebendran in der Halle eine Veranstaltung machen, in der wir erklären, was wir gebaut haben und warum das eine Rolle spielt. Wir können in der Küche das Catering dazu machen, das wir brauchen. Und wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel sagen, wir bauen Umweltsensoren, um die Feinstaubbelastung an der B96 zu messen oder irgendwas anderes zu machen, dann haben wir drüben das Rechenzentrum, in denen all diese Daten ihr Zuhause finden. Und wir das dann quasi auch noch alles verarbeiten können. Und der Teil, der jetzt fehlt, und das ist das, was im nächsten Jahr, also wir fangen im Herbst jetzt schon an, aber was vor allem 2021 dann passieren wird, ist, dass wir uns gerade fragen, wie schaffen wir eigentlich eine Infrastruktur, die quasi auch auf einer Netzebene irgendwie dann das komplementiert. Und wir sind jetzt gerade so ein bisschen im Gespräch mit der Stadt seit einiger Zeit wegen Zugang zu den kommunalen Dächern, Richtfunk, vielleicht die, wir haben so die Idee, dass wir einen Richtfunk-Backbone aufbauen wollen in der Stadt, um den dann als Grundlage zu nutzen, um quasi so Freifunkstyle ein freies WLAN für das gesamte Stadtgebiet auszurollen. Wir überlegen gerade, wie wir gemeinsam mit der Stadt oder auch unabhängig von der Stadt gewisse Glasfasertrassen verlegen könnten. Es gibt so ein paar Dinge, die nahe liegen. Wir möchten eben dieses Hermann-Lorra-Wahn, das gerade aufgebaut wird. Also sind so unterschiedliche Überlegungen, die in Richtung eines gemeinwohlorientierten Netzausbaus hier vor Ort gehen. Und auch das ist nicht zuletzt dieser ganzen Corona-Situation geschuldet. Also wir haben dadurch, dass wir ja sehr eng mit der Schule zusammenarbeiten, in den ersten Wochen, also wir haben so in der Corona-Zeit unterschiedliche Phasen gehabt. Unser Rechenzentrum ist gerade so in Betrieb gegangen, als das losging Anfang des Jahres. Dann haben wir ganz viel Big Blue Button-Infrastruktur ausgerollt, ein bisschen Moodle aufgesetzt für alle möglichen Schulen, mit denen wir so Kontakt hatten. Viele Nachbarschaftsinitiativen, also hier Krisenkultur, nebenan.de und so weiter, da sind auch einige Sachen, die hier bei uns irgendwie laufen. Die digitale Zivilgesellschaft, alle möglichen Dinge, die sich in dieser ganzen Situation auf einmal in Bewegung gesetzt haben. Da konnten wir total gut, hier sehr flexibel und kurzfristig sagen, wir haben hier Kapazitäten und schon hatte unser Rechenzentrum auch einen wirklich guten Daseinszweck, überregional, aber auch für die Region. Gleichzeitig haben wir uns ja überlegt, was ist jetzt mit der Schule? Ich habe dann irgendwann eine Schulung gemacht für die Lehrer hier an unserer Grundschule, wie sie das Big Blue Button benutzen können. Dann haben die ihr Leid geklagt, dass sie von so knapp irgendwas zwischen der Hälfte und zwei Drittel aller Schüler überhaupt nichts gehört haben, seit die zu Hause sind. Dann haben wir uns ein bisschen darüber unterhalten, wie sieht denn überhaupt, wie sehen die Kommunikationswege denn aus? Und was wissen wir eigentlich über die Situation bei den Kindern, was Geräte angeht, Internetzugänge und so weiter, damit die überhaupt aus dieser Webcloud des Landes Brandenburg, die für Schulen bereitgestellt wird, ihre Hausaufgaben runterladen können. Und dann haben wir so einen kleinen Umfragebogen ausgearbeitet, der von der Schule dann verteilt wurde an alle und haben festgestellt, dass das halt katastrophal ist. Und vor allem hat das niemand gedacht. Wir haben irgendwas zwischen 5 und 10 Prozent der Kinder haben Zugriff auf den Drucker. Jeder Lehrer hatte diese implizite Annahme, dass wenn die Arbeitsblätter per E-Mail verschicken, die Kinder sich das schon irgendwie ausdrucken können. Und ich glaube ganz oft ist die Lebensrealität einfach sehr unterschiedlich in ganz unterschiedlichen Familien. So und dann haben wir festgestellt, die wenigsten haben irgendwie einen Laptop. Und auch sehr wenige haben überhaupt Zugriff auf einen Laptop innerhalb der Familie, also vielleicht den von den Eltern oder so. Dann kam die Frage nach dem Internetanschluss. Die meisten, auch das war ein bisschen überraschend, aber eigentlich, wenn man länger drüber nachdenkt, dann auch logisch. Die meisten haben zu Hause keinen DSL-Anschluss. Das ist einfach viel zu teuer. Wir leben hier in einer strukturschwachen Region mit einem substanziellen Anteil an Sozialleistungsempfängern. Die haben halt ein Smartphone mit einer SIM-Karte drin. Und vielleicht haben auch die Kinder irgendwann ein Smartphone mit irgendeiner SIM-Karte drin. Aber keiner der Verträge, die die haben, ist dafür ausgelegt, vom Datenvolumen her, dass da jetzt Videokonferenzen gemacht werden und man den ganzen Tag vielleicht Lehrvideos gucken soll oder Arbeitsblätter runter lädt und hoch lädt und sich halt wirklich in einem ganz anderen Umfang im Internet bewegt. Das funktioniert halt gut, solange alle irgendwie nur WhatsApp machen. Aber das funktioniert halt nicht in dem Moment, wo man das braucht, als Grundlage zum Arbeiten. Dann sind, wenn das nur die Eltern sind, die das haben, die sind tagsüber arbeiten. Dann haben die Kinder in der Zeit, wo sie eigentlich für die Schule arbeiten sollten, nicht unbedingt ein Handy, das jetzt einen Hotspot aufmachen kann. Und selbst wenn man den aufmacht, dann ist halt unter Umständen nach einer oder zwei Wochen das Volumen aufgebraucht und es gibt das nächste Problem. Also haben wir festgestellt, da gibt es ohne Ende zu tun. Und der einzige Weg, wie wir dieses Thema adäquat adressieren können, ist, indem wir sagen, wir möchten, dass in Fürstenberg der Internetzugang Teil der Daseinsvorsorge ist. Und deswegen möchten wir dieses freie WLAN ausbauen, in Fürstenberg, aber auch in den Ortsteilen außenrum, dass einfach so eine Baseline gibt, wo niemand mehr ohne Zugang zum Internet sein muss. Und im besten Fall die Kinder, wenn sie nochmal zu Hause bleiben müssen, auch von zu Hause immer irgendwie lernen und arbeiten können. Wir haben 25 oder 30 Laptops, die wir verteilt haben an Kinder. Wir haben jetzt nochmal 40 weitere organisiert. Wir statten die alle mit so einem Standard Linux Image aus, wo so ein bisschen Software vorbereitet ist. Dann haben alle Kinder die gleiche Lernumgebung, arbeiten mit dem gleichen System. Wir können über Big Blue Button mit den Kids gemeinsam lernen, wie man mit dem Computer lernt. Wir machen jetzt gerade Lernen mit dem Computer zu lernen Kurse hier im Bahnhof. Demnächst auch noch ein bisschen Freiluft draußen. Da haben sich jetzt ein paar Schulen angemeldet, die mit Klassen vorbeikommen wollen, um quasi so ein bisschen unter diesem Schwerpunkt einen Tag hier zu verbringen. Falls die Schule nochmal geschlossen wird, was müssen die Kids eigentlich wissen, damit die besser klarkommen mit ihren digitalen Lernaufgaben? Und gleichzeitig ist das jetzt gerade total überraschend im Gespräch mit der Schule unter Umständen sogar eine Option für alles das, was im Rahmen des Digitalpacks angeschafft wird. Das wäre einfach sagen, wir setzen komplett auf freie Software. Und das ist so naheliegend, wie wahrscheinlich für viele von uns, irgendwie so ein insgeheimer Wunsch, den man ja hätte, der aber offensichtlich bei unserer aktuellen Schulleitung in der Grundschule sogar total auf offene Ohren stößt. Und das wäre natürlich auch absolut mega, wenn jetzt sowas noch funktionieren würde. Und so ist das einfach, im Endeffekt, dass es vielleicht das, auf was es hinausläuft, hier eine Spielwiese, auf der wir gerade Dinge ausprobieren können. Und dieser Infrastrukturteil, der gehört natürlich auch dazu.
Zum Schluss möchte ich von Daniel wissen, was er anderen Leuten raten würde, die ebenfalls in einer ländlichen Region einen Hackspace eröffnen möchten.
Also ich glaube, es gibt unterschiedliche Dinge, die wichtig sind. Und die sind wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen anders gewichtet, je nachdem, wie man so persönlich drauf ist. Aber als allererstes würde ich sagen, dass alle, die im Moment sich damit umtreiben, rauszuziehen, nach Fürstenberg kommen sollten. Also das ist definitiv nicht nur, weil es hier sehr schön ist, und weil ich glaube, dass wir gewisse Dinge vorangebracht haben, sondern im Besonderen, weil man hier nicht ganz bei Null anfängt. Und die ersten Jahre, die wir hier draußen waren, war der Kreis der Leute, die Sachen bewegen wollten, weil sie das als quasi einen neuen Standort für sich begriffen haben. Der war einfach wesentlich kleiner als heute. Und dementsprechend war es auch schwieriger, Dinge zu bewegen. Und wir sind heute an so einem Punkt, wo in den letzten Jahren wirklich substanziell schon Leute hergezogen sind. Und alle die Leute, die hierher kommen, eine andere Art von Gestaltungswillen mitbringen als Leute, die hier schon ihr ganzes Leben hier verbracht haben. Ich glaube, das liegt einfach in der Natur der Sache. Wenn man irgendwann irgendwo groß geworden ist, akzeptiert man viel eher, dass etwas ist, wie es ist. Während man als Neuzugang vielleicht andere Perspektiven mitbringt und auch eine ganz andere Motivation mitbringt, sich irgendwo einzubringen. Und wir sind im Moment hier in einer Situation, wo so eine kritische Masse da ist. Und man jetzt nicht ganz bei Null anfängt einfach. Wenn man sich irgendeinen der vielen anderen Orte auf dem Land aussucht, dann glaube ich, ist das Wichtigste, was man mitnehmen muss, Geduld. Also Geduld im Sinne davon, dass viele Dinge Zeit brauchen. Und das ist das, dass man Leute kennenlernt, dass man vielleicht, dass es Zeit braucht, dass man nicht empfunden wird als irgendein zugezogener Besserwisser oder jemand, der vielleicht verrückte Ideen hat, die erstmal alle bezweifeln, sondern man Zeit braucht, um zu beweisen, dass man an diesen Ideen auch festhält und die auf den Weg bringt und das irgendwie passiert. Und man darüber über Zeit sich eine andere Art von Glaubwürdigkeit verschafft. Das hatten wir hier auch. Am Anfang waren einige Leute so ein bisschen skeptisch. Was wollen die? Die machen so verrückte Computersachen. Hat das überhaupt irgendeine Relevanz für uns? Dann hat sich das aber über Zeit ergeben, dass die Leute festgestellt haben, warum das relevant ist, dass wir an den Sachen, die wir in den Raum gestellt haben, auch festhalten und das irgendwie sich manifestiert. Und diese Geduld braucht man, egal wohin man, glaube ich, geht. Und man sollte auf jeden Fall auch eine gehörige Portion Offenheit mitbringen. Also ich verstehe in meinem Metier vielleicht manche Dinge besser als die Leute hier. Aber es gibt tausend Dinge, die Leute hier besser wissen als ich. Und man muss, glaube ich, man darf nicht irgendwo auflaufen in dieser Vorstellung, dass man da jetzt hingeht, um alles besser zu machen oder so, sondern man muss sich einlassen auf eine Community, die ganz anders gestrickt ist, als das in der Stadt ist. Ich kann unendlich viel lernen von meinen Nachbarn. Und ich kann ganz andere Perspektiven entdecken, manchmal auch Perspektiven, die mir gar nicht gefallen. Ich kann auch Stereotype treffen, die mir nicht gefallen. Vorurteile gegenüber Zugezogenen, gegenüber Deutschen Zugezogenen, vielleicht genauso wie gegenüber Migranten, die hierher kommen. Und gleichzeitig kann ich feststellen, dass das wahrscheinlich in der Regel gar nicht ideologisch geprägt ist, sondern das damit zu tun hat, dass die Leute vielleicht nicht genug Exponierung hatten bisher. Und dann muss man einfach ein bisschen Geduld mitbringen und den Willen, sich davor irgendwie nicht zu verschließen, sondern das zu akzeptieren als Teil einer Gemengelage hier irgendwie. Und dann kommt man vielleicht ins Gespräch und dann stellt man fest, dass sich Dinge auch verändern. Also wir hatten hier so als ein total krasses Beispiel, als die ersten syrischen Familien hier angekommen sind und dann so die ersten Kinder in der Schule waren und sich Freundschaften ergeben haben und die ersten syrischen Kinder dann eingeladen waren auf Geburtstagen bei deutschen Kindern, hatten wir so einen Vater, der hier zu diesen ganz wenigen harten NPD-Leuten gehört, der hat seine Tochter abends auf den Geburtstag abgeholt und hat auch die syrischen Kinder nach Hause gefahren. Der empfand das als eine total normale Sache, die nach Hause zu bringen, weil das gar nicht in seinem Denkraum die Ausländer waren, mit denen er ein Problem hat. Das sind nur die, die mit seinen Kindern in die Schule gehen. Von denen weiß er, dass sie total nett sind. Dann sind das Leute, die sich in eine total gegensätzliche, widersprüchliche Gedankenwelt begeben. Aber der hat definitiv über seine erste Exponierung mit Leuten aus dem arabischen Raum festgestellt, dass sie gar nicht alle so sind, wie er sich das sein Leben lang vorgestellt hat. Diese Dinge brauchen Zeit und die funktionieren, glaube ich, auf dem Land viel besser als in der Stadt, weil sich nicht jeder hier einfach in diese Anonymität zurückziehen kann. Ich glaube, man muss diese Geduld irgendwie mitbringen. Geduld, um eigene Projekte aufzubauen und auch Geduld mit den anderen Leuten, die einfach alle anders drauf sind als man selbst. Weil man sich hier nicht in seiner Filterblase bewegen kann. Und das muss man auch, glaube ich, wissen vorher. Man kann nicht aufs Land ziehen und dann glauben, dass man genauso unter seinesgleichen ist, wie man das vielleicht in der Stadt ist.
Das war Chaos Radio Spezial, der Verstehbahnhof. Ein Hack und Make Space auf dem Land von Daniel Molkenthin. Es sprachen Christina Schavionke und der Autor. Eine Produktion des Chaos Computer Club Berlin.